the single most powerful asset we have
is our mind if it is trained well it can
create enormous wealth in what seems to
be an
instant find the game where you can win
and then commit your life to playing it
and play to
win successful people ask questions they
seek new teachers they're always
learning the problem with having a job
is that it gets in the way of getting
rich start small and dream
[Music]
big if you want to be financially free
you need to become a different person
than the one you are today and let go of
whatever has held you back back in the
past the philosophy of the rich and the
poor is this the rich invest their money
and spend what is left the poor spend
their money and invest what is
[Music]
left sight is what you see with your
eyes vision is what you see with your
mind never say you cannot afford
something that is a poor man's attitude
ask how you can afford
it your future is created by what you do
today not
[Music]
tomorrow the more I risk being rejected
the better my chances are of being
accepted one of the most stupid things
to do is to pretend you you are smart
when you pretend to be smart you are at
the height of
stupidity find out where you are where
you want to be and build a plan to get
[Music]
there most people want everyone else in
the World to Change let me tell you it's
easier to change yourself than to change
everyone
else
people who dream small dreams continue
to live as small
people the richest people in the world
build networks everyone else is trained
to look for
[Music]
work there are those who make things
happen there are those who watch things
happen and there are those who say what
happened skills not theories make you
rich losers quit when they fail winners
fail until they
[Music]
succeed when you come to the boundaries
of what you know it is time to make some
mistakes the ability to sell is the
number one skill in business if you
cannot sell don't bother thinking about
becoming a business
owner most people are too lazy to think
instead of learning something new they
think the same thought day after
day education is cheap experience is
expensive there are no mistakes in life
just learning
opportunities
[Music]
the love of money is not the root of all
evil the lack of money is the root of
all
evil when you are forced to think you
expand your mental capacity when you
expand your mental capacity your wealth
increases making mistakes isn't enough
to become great you must also admit the
mistake and then learn learn how to turn
the mistake into an
advantage in today's rapidly changing
world the people who are not taking
risks are the real Risk
Takers excuses are a dime a dozen that's
why the poor have so many of
them people need to wake up and realize
that life doesn't wait for you if you
want something get up and go after
it if you want to be rich serve more
[Music]
people it is easy to stay the same it is
not easy to change most people choose to
stay the same all their
lives it does not take money to make
money a akake is a signal that it is
time to learn something new something
you didn't know
[Music]
before there are no bad business and
investment opportunities but there are
bad entrepreneurs and
investors if you want to go somewhere it
is best to find someone who has already
been
there success is a poor teacher we learn
the most about ourselves when we fail so
don't be afraid of failing failing is
part of the process of success you
cannot have success without
[Music]
failure The Wealthy by luxuries last
while the poor in middle class tend to
buy luxuries first why emotional
discipline or lack of
[Music]
it when times are bad is when the real
entrepreneurs
[Music]
emerge sometimes you win sometimes you
learn you get one life live it in a way
that inspires
[Music]
someone when I started my last business
I didn't receive a paycheck for 13
months the average person can't handle
that
pressure
[Music]
getting rich begins with the right
mindset the right words and the right
[Music]
plan sometimes what is right for you at
the beginning of your life is not right
for you at the end of your
life business is like a wheelbarrow
nothing happens until you start
[Music]
pushing this business and investing are
team
sports the hardest part of Change is
Going Through The
Unknown Financial struggle is often the
direct result of people working all
their lives for someone
else being an entrepreneur is simply
going from one mistake to the next you
must have the fortitude to
[Music]
continue the most life- destroying word
of all is this
tomorrow intelligence solves problems
and produces money money without
Financial intelligence is money soon
[Music]
gone the size of your success is
measured by the strength of your desire
the size of your dream and and how you
handle disappointment along the
[Music]
way the most successful people are
Mavericks who aren't afraid to ask why
especially when everyone thinks it's
obvious hoping drains your energy action
creates
energy the more a person seeks security
the more that person gives up control
over over his
life everyone can tell you the risk an
entrepreneur can see the
reward the only difference between a
rich person and a poor person is how
they use their
[Music]
time your choices decide your fate take
the time to make the right ones if you
make a mistake that's fine learn from it
and don't make it
again money is really just an
idea talk is cheap learn to listen with
your eyes actions do speak louder than
words watch what a person does more than
what he
says the moment you make passive income
and portfolio income a part of your life
your life will change those words will
become
[Music]
flesh if you realize that you're the
problem then you can change yourself
learn something and grow wiser don't
blame other people for your
problems workers work hard enough to not
be fired and business owners pay just
enough so that workers won't
[Music]
quit
without a strong reason or purpose
anything in life is
hard winners are not afraid of losing
losers are failure is part of the
process of success people who avoid
failure Miss
success if you want to be rich you need
to develop your vision you must be
standing on the Edge of Time gazing into
the
future
the fear of being different prevents
most people from seeking new ways to
solve their
problems don't be addicted to money work
to learn don't work for money work for
knowledge the trouble with school is
they give you the answer then they give
you the exam that's not
life
it's more important to grow your income
than to cut your expenses it's more
important to grow your spirit than to
cut your
[Music]
dreams the most successful people in
life are the ones who ask questions
they're always learning they're always
growing they're always
[Music]
pushing complaining about your current
position in life is worthless have a
spine to do something about about it
instead in the real world the smartest
people are those who make mistakes and
learn in school the smartest people
don't make
[Music]
mistakes it's not what you say out of
your mouth that determines your life
it's what you whisper to
[Music]
yourself
it's easier to stand on the sidelines
criticize and say why you shouldn't do
something the sidelines are crowded get
in the
game most people in their drive to get
rich are trying to build an Empire State
Building on a 6-in
slab more money seldom solves someone's
money problems
the more we know about the power of
money the more distant we grow from our
teachers and our
[Music]
classmates an asset puts money in my
pocket a liability takes money out of my
[Music]
pocket a person can be highly educated
professionally successful and
financially
illiterate
by not understanding money the vast
majority of people allow its awesome
power to control
them an intelligent person hires people
who are more intelligent than he
is I'd rather welcome change than cling
to the
past the greater your financial
intelligence the easier it is to tell
whether a deal is
good if you're still doing what Mommy
and Daddy said for you to do go to
school get a job save money you're
[Music]
losing